hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar pursuing private foundation and
corporate grant opportunities in life
science research our presenter today is
dr. Devin Brewer editor writer
scientific adviser and statistical
consultant my name is Chrissy Joe Allen
of laberd's and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by Leica Microsystems for more
information on our sponsor please visit
like a dash Microsystems comm okay now
let's get started I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and someone
will be able to help you out Devin will
be answering a portion of these
questions live following the
presentation and any of these questions
that we don't answer live will receive a
written response via the email address
that was provided at the time of
registration
you will also see multiple tabs at the
top of your screen if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on that support tab or you can report
your problem by using the ask a question
box you can also share this webinar on
your personal social media just click on
the social sharing tab and let your
friends and colleagues know about
today's mighty bin additionally this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits at
the end of the viewing of this
presentation just click on the
continuing education credit tab and
follow the process to obtain your credit
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
dr. devon brewer dr. brewer is an editor
writer scientific advisor and
statistical consultant he has 25 years
of experience in writing successful
grant proposals in the health sciences
he has been a principal investigator on
several grants and a key contributor to
many others dr. brewer has written
funded proposals and are reviewed
proposals for NIH NSF CDC HRSA and MRC
UK private foundations and other
agencies as a scientific adviser and
writer with science Docs
he helps researchers develop and compose
effective proposals and manuscripts you
may view dr. Brewers biography in the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr. brewer you may now begin your
presentation
hi I'm going to talk about pursuing
private foundation and corporate
research grant opportunities the
information I give applies to North
America but much of what I describe may
be relevant to other parts of the world
too
because I will give advice about how to
apply
excuse me about how to find and apply
for foundation in corporate research
work research grants let me tell you a
little bit about my experience for over
26 years I have written successful grant
proposals and the Health Sciences I have
been the principal investigator on
several grants and a key contributor to
many others I have written funded
proposals or reviewed proposals for many
national government funding agencies in
the United States and United Kingdom as
well as for private foundations and
other organizations
as a scientific adviser and writer with
science stocks I help researchers
develop and compose effective
manuscripts and proposals including to
private foundations and corporations
I'll begin this tour today with a little
background on private foundation in
corporate grants next I will describe
some reasons why researchers pursue such
funding and essential matters to
consider before doing so
then I will review how to find him from
how to find information about found
Foundation and corporate research grant
opportunities and discuss some common
procedures and approaches for applying
at the end I'll highlight some best
practices to follow when developing a
research grant proposal of any kind
there are approximately 90,000 private
foundations in the United States many
private foundations give grants for
charitable purposes
their funds come from an individual
family corporation or another group
these individuals and groups often run
their foundations personally or are
closely involved
in Canada there are about 3,000
grant-making foundations
many corporations also give to
charitable causes directly
although often not legally classified as
foundations many disease-specific
non-profitable charitable organizations
also give research grants
for the purposes of this webinar I
categorize such charities as foundations
just one of many kinds of activities
that a foundation or corporation may
support
Foundation and corporate grants are for
nonprofit organizations only this means
that universities and colleges are
eligible for a foundation or corporate
grant the individuals and for-profit
for-profit businesses typically or not
however sometimes a foundation or
corporation holds a challenge type of
contest related to a specific problem
making proposals from any individual or
kind of organization the XPrize
Foundation is an example of this
Foundation and corporate grants differ
from government agency grants in several
key ways
research grants given by foundations and
corporations tend to be smaller than
those given by government agencies
and corporations also tend to focus more
on applied research and translation to
practical uses than do government
funding agencies
in addition compared to government
agency research grants Foundation and
corporate grants may have fewer
bureaucratic requirements for grantees
furthermore Foundation and corporate
grants also tend not to include much or
any support for indirect costs also
known as overhead or infrastructure
charges
they fund many kinds of activities
foundations and corporations usually
have less experience with research and
researchers than government agencies
that fund research
nations and corporations tend to have
less standardized proposal formats and
proposal reviewers might not include any
scientists
scientific merit might be only one of
several factors in their funding
decisions
why might you want to seek funding from
private foundations and corporations
one reason might be to avoid the
ever-increasing complexity and number of
forms in applying for government funding
most foundations and corporations have
quite simple application processes in
comparison
Foundations probably offer many more
fellowship opportunities as well as
awards based on an individual
investigators record and promise than do
government research agencies
funding that is not project-based
project-based can give you intellectual
and scientific freedom to do the
research you think is most important
rather than what biased timid or
unimaginative peers prioritize
of course a natural reason to seek
Foundation and corporate support for
your research is that you cannot obtain
it from government or other sources
also foundations and corporations are
much more likely to fund unusual
projects those that are truly innovative
unconventional or risky than government
agencies
foundations and corporations maybe less
bound to disciplinary shortsightedness
and the political struggles among
academics
moreover Foundation and corporate
funding may be necessary even with
government support for especially large
projects that no one sponsor can afford
on its own
before seeking a foundation or corporate
research grant you should consider
several matters first
you might need to reduce the size of
your project or break it into smaller
independent pieces to get support from
foundations and corporations foundations
and corporations often want to have an
identifiable project or part of a
project that is theirs that is one that
day alone support
private funders tend to have less money
to give so lean budgets are essential
though some foundations do support basic
research it is important to present your
plans as having a clear connection to
real world concerns rather than simply
academic goals
foundations and corporations generally
want research focused on practical
problems
you should check with administrators in
your organization before seeking a
foundation or corporate grid some
research organizations will not accept
grants that do not cover indirect costs
or some amount of them
it is more difficult to find research
grant opportunities from private
foundations and corporations than it is
from government funding agencies
however with some time and effort you
can use a few basic strategies and
resources to find potential private
funders
colleagues and peers who do research
similar to your own what private sources
of funding they have received for their
work you can also identify other private
funders by reading acknowledgement
sections of articles in your area of
research
you can find many possibly relevant
private foundations and corporations by
searching the worldwide web
most private funders of life science
research focus on particular human
diseases so an example set of search
terms might be the name of the disease
and research and charity
you could also repeat the search but
replace charity with foundation and then
search again by replacing it with grant
topic isn't related to a disease you can
try using the name of your subject
instead of the name of a disease
scholar is an excellent additional
resource it indexes the full-text of the
published scientific literature
including the acknowledgement sections
in articles so an example search of
Google Scholar might include the name of
a disease and grant and foundation but
not the phrase National Science
Foundation
Matt shown here is the syntax necessary
to do this in Google Scholar
check with your institutions grants and
contracts office about potential
non-government funders for your research
if your institution has a foundation and
corporate funding office check they're
too often these off offices receive news
about new funding opportunities and
share it with researchers
sometimes thunders limit the number of
applications they will allow from each
institution especially for individual
based awards rather than project-based
grants
administrators in these offices can
guide you on these matters
several commercial subscription services
that compile information on research
grant opportunities and research funders
including private foundations and
corporations
the most popular services include grant
domain grant forward pivot and research
professional many of these services are
international covering opportunities for
researchers in different countries
other services give you access to the
databases or to databases on private
foundations with some information on
their past grant making activity
the Foundation Center covers the United
States and grant connect covers Canada
those databases can help you identify
the many foundations especially smaller
ones that don't promote their grant
opportunities
your institutions grants and contracts
office Foundation and corporate funding
office where library may subscribe to
one or more of these services or a near
a nearby university might also subscribe
if your own institution doesn't have any
subscriptions
there are also free directories that are
generally generally less comprehensive
or detailed but still can help you find
potential suitable funders I give a
small sample here of what exists for
instance the National Organization of
rare diseases lists hundreds of patient
lead rare disease organizations most of
which fund research
Anthropy news digest has a searchable
database on all currently active
requests for proposals it has received
from foundations
Louisville central also shows open
research grant opportunities mostly from
private funders
fargo bank shows information on all the
foundations for which it provides
administrative and other support
and charity Durer has a searchable
database on all grant-making foundations
in Canada
once you have identified potential
funders prioritize them in terms of how
well their past grants an interest
profile fits with your work target those
that match best
are several useful approaches to
applying for grants from foundations and
corporations
first discuss your project ideas with
representatives of the funder to gauge
their interest in possible ways of
presenting your proposal to them
however often there is no one available
at the foundation or corporation who
might discuss grant ideas with you or
give you further insight to the funders
priorities and inclinations
so instead you could try to find past
grantees and ask them for their
impressions of the funders orientation
and preferences
foundations and corporations usually
asks that potential applicants first
submit a letter of intent or a letter of
interest funders review the letters and
then invite full proposals from those
grant seekers in whom they are most
interested
if there are no instructions for the
content and format of a letter summarise
your planned project briefly in a page
or two in layman's terms
typically it is also necessary to write
proposals for a lay audience as
reviewers and/or decision makers that
the funder may include few scientists or
a few scientists in your specialty
this means no jargon or very limited
jargon you define well no or very
limited acronyms and no complex sentence
structures
scientists tend to struggle with such
requirements so plan to spend a lot of
time to craft your proposal in a simple
concise and clear way
requirements vary widely across private
funders unless a funder has instructed
otherwise include all of the elements
that appear in a government agency
proposal such as a description of the
problem you intend to address how your
project might advance the state of
knowledge and why it is important
details on what you plan to do
problems that might occur in the project
and how you anticipate handling them
your own background and expertise and
that of your team if it is a group
effort that is why are you qualified to
do the project
other relevant research that has been
done before and what is new or different
about your project
why you were seeking support from this
funder and not more common sources such
as a government agency
specification of your budgeted expenses
schedule that lists what you will
deliver to the funder in return for its
support
a list of references cited and an
abstract or overall proposal summary
finally it is crucial that you tailor
your letter and proposal to each Thunder
highlight how your project focuses on
the funders priorities and goals in
effect you are a vendor selling a
project and the funder is your customer
demonstrate how your project will meet
your customers needs and desires
improve your chances of getting funded
by following best practices for
developing a grant proposal regardless
of Thunder
aside several months to develop and
prepare your proposal
closely with administrators at your
institution it involved them early in
the process to avoid having problems
later
follow all application instructions the
Thunderer gives precisely
how to write an effective proposal to
private funders by studying colleagues
or others successful proposals to
foundations and corporations
lastly get critical free feedback on
your proposal from colleagues and revise
accordingly before submission
I discuss these and other essentials at
length in another video at the link at
the link shown here is dot GD slash
grant 13
there are also other resources you can
draw on at science Docs we help
researchers in all phases of developing
and writing grant proposals and
manuscripts we have experts in every
specialty ready to assist you can learn
more at science talks calm
okay I'd like to open it up for
questions
you
Thank You dr. brewer for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar if you have a question - you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions we
have time for okay that some great
questions already coming in Oh
dr. brewer let's start with this one is
already having grants from government
agencies for other projects a good
reason for applying for a foundational
grant
well I don't think it really makes a
difference one way or the other I don't
think a ound ation would discriminate
against a grant seeker that already has
grants from government agencies for
other projects and it might actually
help that grant seeker to have that kind
of background but either way I don't
think it makes a huge difference
Thank You dr. brewer our next question
where can I find a non foundation
disease specific charities list
um well most of the disease-specific
charities whether they're legally
they're classified as a foundation or
not often doesn't really make a
difference from the grant seekers
perspective because they both foundation
charities and non foundation charities
frequently offer grants but in terms of
finding all those opportunities from the
slides I presented about how to search
for to identify these kinds of
foundation and other charitable funders
and the lists like the National
Organization for rare diseases has
hundreds of disease specific charities
for rare diseases
dr. burr we've question comes in I am a
scientist staff not faculty am I
qualified to apply for a grant
from the perspective of a foundation or
corporation very likely yes
the key question usually though is
whether your institution your
organization will accept having you be
the principal investigator on a grant
sometimes if they don't allow that you
might be able to find a faculty person
that will serve as the principal
investigator at least in name only where
you actually do all the prep preparatory
work in developing the proposal and
doing all that and maybe even executing
all the work if it were to get funded so
usually there's a an administrative
workaround at most institutions to
handle that situation
dr. brewer is there a source of funds
for for-profit organization
so most private foundations in charities
don't or either either don't or cannot
give grants to private individuals or
private companies or firms there are a
few exceptions like I mentioned the
XPrize Foundation and similar kinds of
opportunities that are often presented
as challenges you know you know where
the funder wants a solution to a
particular problem or a class of
problems and seeks innovative responses
to that problem and oftentimes those
kinds of opportunities do not restrict
you know the grantees to be nonprofit or
academic organizations so those are the
kinds of opportunities that are best for
private firms
Thank You dr. brewer what is the average
success rate for a private foundation or
corporate grants
you know there's no there's no way
really to say I mean number one most
foundations and corporations don't offer
any statistics on their their funding
rates but even more important than that
is that there is no it's a very diverse
set of funders you're talking about
thousands of in just North America alone
thousands of foundations and
corporations that give grants and so
there are they're very different from
each other so it's it's very difficult
to say what I can say is that there are
quite a few researchers that do obtain
funding from these sources and so that
that would at least suggest that the
funding rates are high enough to make
pursuing them worthwhile
thank you dr. brewer now we have a
question coming in asking if this
webinar is available for review and yes
it is this webcast can be viewed
on-demand following our live
presentation and Mavericks will alert
you via email when it is available for
replay and I also want to make note that
you can continue to submit questions
during that on-demand period and dr.
brewer will answer those questions yes
the email address you provided at your
time of registration so let's continue
with our questions dr. brewer
all right are there any styles of
proposals that appeal to NGOs rather
than Geo's and what areas of my proposal
should I emphasize more than others
okay let me we find this question again
Oh
that appeal to NGOs so I assume for NGOs
here I assume the questioner is asking
about found NGOs meaning Foundation or
charity charitable funders in terms of
the style the style of the proposal is
going to vary again dramatically
depending on the particular Thunder so
you just have to study all the
information available about what what
their expectations are for a proposal
and do your background research try to
find other people that have been funded
by this organization and ask them for
advice or just tips on on how to present
your ideas what areas of my proposal
should I emphasize more than others
again that's going to vary depend upon
the particular funder but in general
compared to government agency proposals
the clear emphasis for most private
foundations and corporations is for
something that has a tangible practical
applied benefit and not just mere
building of knowledge or advancing
science that there's got to be some
generally they want to see some sort of
movement toward practical payoff so
that's something that many researchers
struggle with even if their work is
applied to be able to communicate their
mission and and how exactly their
scientific research is going to relate
to these real world concerns
Thank You dr. brewer moving on to my
next question do the databases you
mentioned provide information on
corporate funding sources and is there a
difference between getting funding from
corporate sources versus Foundation
so the the corporate funding sources are
probably they're definitely definitely
more difficult to identify a few of them
do a few of the sources that I mentioned
do make reference to corporations that
give grants but most of them you'll put
most corporations that give grants you
will probably identify through doing the
web searches and searches on Google
Scholar and also just your own personal
or your colleagues personal connections
and that's also you know a very limited
way to identify opportunities but all
but a good one if if your network of
associates happen to have connections to
such firms is there a difference between
getting funding from corporate sources
versus a foundation well there's
again that's going to vary based upon
the particular corporation or foundation
corporate grants that they are if you
they're probably less familiar with the
machinery of academic and research
institutions so the idea of indirect
costs may be completely foreign to them
until you meant you might not be able to
get indirect costs at all from many
corporates grant sources whereas some
foundations are at least familiar
familiar with the concept and may pay a
token indirect cost rate but again you
know the details of whether it's better
to get one from one source or another
you know that just depends upon the
particular funder but in terms of your
purposes you know if you get funding for
a project you know money is money and it
still would allow you to do what you
want to do
Thank You dr. brewer next question do
you feel that NGOs in the US are better
aligned to support international
research projects than their
counterparts in Ex us
well that's a good question
I don't have much experience with their
counterparts in terms of being funders
of research outside of the United States
I would guess that for funders in the
english-speaking world outside of the
United States and in Western Europe that
there would be generally similar but
again you know I can't say based upon my
experience I do get the impression that
particularly in Europe the bureaucratic
requirements for funding tend to be much
higher at least in government grants
compared to grants in the United States
dr. brewer will corporate grants have
restrictions on some research activities
for example publishing
that would depend upon the particular
funder but for most corporate research
grants you know they can their grants
not partnerships or contracts so I'm
just talking about grants and so grants
usually don't come with those kinds of
restrictions because the corporate
research grants are typically coming out
of the charitable efforts the charitable
wing of a corporation and not the
mainline of that corporations business
where can I find grants for equipment
well that's
question it depends upon what the
purpose of the equipment is again you
you if you would have to align your
interest in the equipment to the goals
of the funder but I am not aware of any
foundations or corporations that just
give grants or have an interest in
giving grants to support purchasing of
equipment generically by researchers
are there any foundations or sources
that fund equipment and I guess we're
piggybacking on that previous question
any foundations or sources that fund
equipment our lab development grants
um there maybe I'm not I can't think of
any right off the top of my head there
are grants that are focused on
individuals and developing individuals
sometimes young investigators or new
investigators and sometimes more senior
ones and those are grants that are you
know day or they may even be called a
fellowship or they may come under
different names different labels but
there are many competitive fellowship
and grants to individual grants awarded
to individual researchers and in those
cases I would imagine that many are much
of the funds could be used to develop
ones lab
akin postdocs seek a private foundation
grant
this is similar to a prior question so
from the perspective of the Thunder
usually the status of or the position of
a researcher within their institution
usually isn't a critical matter it's not
something that they would discriminate
against and restrict to one class of
employee or faculties and another key
issue is whether your institution your
your organization will let you apply as
a principal investigator on a grant and
if you're not able to do that usually
there's a way to arrange someone who is
eligible to apply within your
organization and to work with them and
they might be more of a nominal
principal investigator where you would
do the work but you know institutionally
you would not be the the project later
dr. Berger do these foundations also
fund training
yes many foundations do support training
generically if you're referring to like
a training grant you know to support say
postdocs or clinical fellows or
something of that nature then you know
those particular kinds of things you
know there are more limited
opportunities but if you were to have
something if you were talking about
training you know like to conduct a
workshop to train researchers in some
important technique or some important
approach you know there might be more
more interest in that you know if you
can connect it to the funders missions
dr. brewer what is the best route for a
holder of a provisional patent that
needs funding fairly quickly and they
would need ten to a hundred million
that's usually way beyond the scope of
what a private foundation or corporate
grant would be able to support as I
mentioned before private firms and
companies are usually not eligible to
receive corporate grants and private
foundation grants so that's more in the
venture capital startup funding
commercial startup funding space as
opposed to the private foundation in
corporate grant space
and we have time for just one or two
more um what about funding by sovereign
funds
I don't have any experience with funding
from sovereign funds and I would imagine
so III really can't answer that
and February of let's rock with this
final question for a private company do
you have an estimate for percentage
effort or range for the p i-- that they
would view as acceptable
I have several rewards through this
route and this is always a battle
and this is for
let me just find this question again I'm
sorry
a private company again it's going to be
the number of opportunities for funding
from a private foundation or corporation
are going to be very limited in their
goal they're going to tend to be these
types of challenged efforts we're so in
those cases where you're responding to
some kind of X X Prize or related kind
of challenge oftentimes they're not
funding you know the the details of who
does what and percentage of time those
kinds of things tend not to be material
factors in those kinds of competitions
and I'm going to squeeze in one last
question what about SBIR grants or
startup
those are great for for startups SBIRS
are our government grants in the United
States you know for example from NIH or
NSF or CDC so that's uh that's another
ballgame that's the government side
today I'm just talking about private
foundations and corporations
February thank you so much for your time
today
I would also like to thank collaborates
and are sponsored by Khan Microsystems
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I would like to
thank the audience for joining us and
for their interesting questions we had
quite a few questions we were not able
to answer and we know that you can
continue to submit questions during the
on-demand period so those questions will
be answered via the email address you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
Mavericks will alert you via email today
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day